- [Graham] So I'm here
at Dig This Las Vegas.
It's a construction equipment playground
where you can live out
your childhood dreams
of being able to operate heavy machinery
like bulldozers and excavators.
But first, gotta sign some waivers,
gotta take a breathalyzer
test which is very important.
And then you gotta put on this vest here
for safety reasons.
Before I head out to the playground,
I have to take a 10 to 15
minute safety training course
to make sure I'm safe out there.
That's it, that's the safety course.
I guess I'm ready.
- [Junior] My name's Junior Diaz.
I am an instructor and I teach people
how to have fun on heavy equipment
that they have never been on
any equipment in their life.
Okay, rotate that cab to
the left as hard as you can.
Faster, faster, come on, commit.
There it is.
You gonna do that push up or what.
Oh ya, get that first groove.
Good job.
Alright, let's bring 'em up.
Bring it up out of the hole.
Good job.
How was that?
- [Graham] That was awesome, man.
Man, that is such a blast.
I mean it's so cool to be in charge
of such a big, powerful machine.
- Did you get your mind
off life for a moment?
- I did, you know.
When I was moving that dirt
and stacking those tires
it was just a way for
me to kind of zone out.
Just focus on simple tasks.
- [Junior] And that's what
we want you guys to do
when you come out to Vegas,
is have fun and tap into
your inner childhood
and have fun.
- Thank you so much, sir.
That was great.
- [Graham] What was the biggest challenge
you think I had out there?
- Biggest challenge for you, I would say
is getting your right from left down.